I always feel like I'm on the presser
piece of papinka conversation of do you
know that so many people have been
pulled out of poverty and things are so
great now oh really I must be imagining
all this terrible misery that I'm seeing
everywhere all of this Despair and
nihilism and Desperation I must be
imagining it I must be imagining a
spiritual void at the very core of our
culture because I've Just Seen now that
you've told me that it's never been as
good I know like you know I respect uh
Professor Jordan throughout history
people are needs people but for me
that's
that's not bold enough people this is it
the old idea is dead the new ideas must
emerge it's going to require new
alliances it's going to require new
conversations if we are unwilling to
have them we are going to experience new
forms of authoritarianism and
centralization
foreign
says you know they promised us flying
cars and we got 140 characters you know
in essence we've sort of stopped
innovating now and we're just Doom
scrolling all day long remember remember
back in our day when the internet
stopped you'd go to a page and it would
stop at the bottom oh yeah remember that
and then they got rid of that so you
just scroll forever and it never stops
and you're looking for more more
craziness yes it's nihilistic I kind of
sense that you're you're more
libertarian than anything else even
though people are always like he's a the
people on the right are always like he's
a lefty but I like him something like
that that's that's what they do let's
see you're kind of like
that's there could be a movie in that
they said that but but I sense you're
mostly like you're you're talking about
decentralization you're talking about
local communities you're you're talking
about taking power away and that kind of
stuff like you're mostly just Live and
Let Live I mean the shows stay free
right like yes I suppose when people
talk about libertarianism sometimes
there's the so is that the suggestion
that we uh do not have a duty and
obligation to love and care for one
another my I suppose I don't feel that
that needs to be mandated by uh at the
end of a gun right that people can love
one another consensually and that we can
organize in various different publics we
can have the maximum amount of democracy
that we can honor the highest aspects of
our nature that broadly speaking I would
respond sympathetically to a person
suffering if I could see them what I'm
beginning to feel is that we have become
uh this joint it that we have there's
been an aberration from the conditions
of our origin there's no nothing in our
Evolution that suggests that we would be
able to live in societies of 300 million
people let alone 7 billion people whilst
that is part of the reality that we're
on a rock in Infinite Space we are also
in communities and I like that phrase
that I think I heard from Helena nor
birkoge uh act local think Global so
like we can have as much democracy in
our community as possible that we allow
people to organize their communities
however they want to unless it has a
negative impact on another Community or
the individuals within that Community
are not happy with it and that we have
to accept that there are many different
ways of Being Human traditional ways new
and emergent ways new roles new
identities allow people to be who they
are allow people to have as much
democracy in their schools as much
democracy in there in there even Law and
Order or be Democratic in my country for
example I heard like I respect very much
people that are working Services because
I understand the value of sacrifice and
I have friends that will work in the
police will thank God and like I I feel
that wouldn't it be good if the forces
of uh you know even law enforcement is a
phrase that's we've got some that you
know as a true uh an anarchist
libertarian I have some issues with
because who do you mandate to you know
because the relationship between
sovereignty and the governed is
traditionally being you give us taxis we
won't get you won't let you get killed
by Bandits or whatever but maybe that'll
be the basics of it yeah you know those
Bandits they could get you anytime give
and show me your money and we'll protect
you from it but what I feel Dave is that
uh it would be nice if there were
consensual policing consensual
governance you live in the area like
it's a sort of localism like this phrase
they're I suppose do have like
particular phrases and ideas that have
sort of stayed in the sphere of your
awareness for a long while and they
start to become part of your personal
philosophy in my case when Gandhi said
at the point of Indian independence this
is a country of 70 000 Villages each one
should be fully independent trading only
where necessary running and governing
themselves there's no point in US
kicking out the British then replicating
the very institutions that they
installed and it seems that we are doing
this now globally sets of
institutionalized power whether they're
corporate or state that don't allow
Ordinary People to have very much
Freedom it's interesting because you're
you're basically I think selling me from
an American perspective you're selling
federalism I mean the idea that the
states should basically do everything
locally and that we should have some
structure above that but it should
probably be way weaker than this crazy
structure that nobody believes in now
that is completely ineffective and
probably very authoritarian oh if that's
the way that you turn it then yeah so
federalism the idea that the states
basically I'm as a Floridian
everything that goes on with my life
should have to do with Florida and the
laws of Florida the U.S government the
federal government should have basically
nothing to do with me except guard the
borders and you know a couple that make
sure the states aren't at War a couple
other things like that yeah leave
everyone alone I suppose you'll be nice
for you guys to have that in the UK huh
what about I suppose look the point of
the state is obviously supposed to be in
order to prevent external attack
military I mean or gargantuan
corporatism one needs a state that can
support the collective will of the
people that elected them now given that
the for some time and this would include
both in my view both administrations
both political parties that they're so
damn near to equal that to quarrel about
which one is superior would be I would
consider literally a waste of time even
now after covert because that because I
would agree with you for for most I
think we're roughly the same age for
most of our Lives yeah but I think
something shifted in kovid where it's
very very clear like the Republicans
they ain't great but like they're much
less
we ain't great but you get this
Healthcare oh yeah we ain't great but we
were bearing covered we ain't great
off
off then yeah we stayed open here
it's why I moved here right that's
something that's something sure thanks
for something yeah thanks you know like
that's that that's I can't get hard for
that conversation yeah for like oh is it
a bit better right and that really was
the point with when you were doing the
Fox News MSN yeah but that is the point
that was the same point yeah yeah it's
like let's do better like because also
like you know if I always feel like I'm
on the presser piece of the Pinker
conversation of do you know that so many
people have been pulled out of poverty
and things are so great now oh really I
must be imagining all this terrible
misery that I'm seeing everywhere all of
this Despair and nihilism and
Desperation I must be imagining it I
must be imagining a spiritual void at
the very core of our culture because
I've Just Seen now that you've told me
that there's never been as good I know
like you know I respect uh Professor
Jordan throughout history people you
know that but for me that's
apology that's not bold enough people
this is it the old idea is dead the new
ideas must emerge it's going to require
new alliances it's going to require new
conversations if we are unwilling to
have them we are going to experience new
forms of authoritarianism and
centralization it's already happening
both political parties have been
co-opted by the same corporate forces
they will behave in the same way now I
know that in my understanding is that
you have um you know like that you
understand is that you're let down with
Ron DeSantis and I don't know very much
about him except I feel like I read like
about that uh and like giving good deal
in the lever the other day giving good
deals to the energy folks and
subsidizing things you know like I don't
feel like anybody that's operating
within that system is capable of
genuinely representing the will of the
people and I'm not saying like the
Rhonda Sanders is particularly bad but
no and I know he's super popular here I
know people love him and I would say
he's particularly good here I know he's
in aberration but I get your your
broader point is that if you're still
operating within the system that has the
system itself that is
so I fully accept that yeah and also I
don't think I don't think any
politicians whether it's DeSantis or if
you brought back George Washington I
don't think they're Gods they're just
people right that's right yeah so he's
operating within a system I would say
he's he's the best that we can get out
of this system if you're looking for
more uncensored opinions from today's
thought leaders check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a wide variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist all
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification Bell